disney's peter pan has been loved by
families for generations
unfortunately this animated classic
hasn't aged entirely well
over the years much of this goes over
kids heads but older viewers might be
surprised by some scenes
for good or bad here are things that
only adults notice in peter pan
as a child it feels perfectly innocent
to fantasize about some magical being
coming to your window to take you away
on adventures in faraway lands
as an adult however the thought of
strange boys visiting underage daughters
via bedroom windows
is much less charming when wendy claims
peter pan has been to the nursery before
and must surely be coming again because
she'd found his shadow her mother seems
a bit perplexed
her father on the other hand brushes it
off as childish fiddle fattle and mocks
his wife's concern
goodness gracious whatever shall we do
however had the same conversation been
with more literal or protective
guardians
peter likely would have found a father
waiting with his shotgun
in that nursery instead of a pining
unattended wendy
at the very least it would have been
wise to leave the family dog nana in the
house with the kids
rather than tied up outside on top of
that the grown mind can't help but
question mr and mrs darling's decision
to leave their young children home alone
for hours without any sort of adult
supervision
if you're not going to have your dog
protect your children while you're out
partying at least
find a human to babysit fairies are some
of the most iconic creatures in the
worlds of fantasy but their disposition
varies widely between sources
in some instances they're benevolent and
wise like cinderella's fairy godmother
while other portrayals of the magical
beings
show a much darker and malevolent nature
peter pan's sidekick tinkerbell seems to
lie somewhere in the middle
tink displays a mean jealous streak the
moment she learns wendy will be
accompanying them back to neverland
going so far as to make an attempt on
her life without peter's knowledge
after abandoning wendy while flying to
peter's hideout hangman's tree
tinkerbell tells the awaiting lost boys
that he gave orders to shoot down a
terrible wendy bird
spotted in the skies sadly the lost boys
followed tinker bell's instructions and
attack her but peter manages to fly over
just in time to save wendy from crashing
down
onto the jagged rocks below when peter
asks tinkerbell if she's guilty or not
guilty of attempting to get wendy shot
down she has an
honest and disturbing response guilty
don't you know you might have killed her
after being banished for her malicious
plot tink makes things even worse by
turning on peter disclosing his hideout
to his
arch-nemesis captain hook thankfully she
redeems herself in the end by saving
peter from a bomb that hook disguises as
a gift but still
it doesn't excuse tink's attempt to
plant wendy's six feet under
being a child forever sounds pretty
liberating on the surface but when
examined more deeply it definitely has a
dark side
while infantile behavior brings carefree
fun and spontaneity it can also
cultivate a short-sighted and selfish
nature this is exhibited time and time
again by peter pan who repeatedly puts
others in danger thanks to his immature
actions and motives
from the moment he's introduced he
constantly makes everything about
himself
as a kid it's easy to mistake peter's
decision to take wendy and her brothers
to neverland as a form of liberation and
a heroic rescue from growing up
which george tells wendy she'll have to
do starting the next day by moving out
of the nursery with her brothers and
into her own room
however more mature viewers are apt to
note that peter only invites them to
neverland because wendy's imminent
relocation would put an end to her
adventure stories
and peter truly loves these tales
because they're about him
but the character's dark side doesn't
stop there peter also treats all the
females in his life like trinkets rather
than people quickly moving on to the
next shiny thing in front of him like
when he leaves wendy behind for tiger
lily
to top it off he occasionally drops
misogynistic insights and demands that
haven't aged well
at all girls talk too much yes
girls talk to them oh well
get on with it girl my name is wendy
when watching peter pan adult viewers
can't help but notice disturbing levels
of racism in the classic film
it's so bad that disney plus even added
a disclaimer before the film warning
viewers about
quote negative depictions and or
mistreatment of people or cultures
not only does this film depict native
americans in horrifically prejudiced
ways
the movie is carpet bombed with racist
slurs against them
everyone from innocent children and the
heroic pan to the villainous captain
hook
casually speak of them as savages and
much worse
the poor treatment of native americans
and other first nations people
culminates in a sing-along titled what
makes the red man red which is loaded
with cultural appropriation
and racist stereotypes early in the film
we learned that captain hook has a
perfectly viable reason for being so
upset with peter pan
after all he's responsible for hook
having a hook in the first place
during a skirmish with the villain peter
cut off hook's hand
and fed it to a nearby crocodile who
then developed a taste for the pirate
leader's flesh
as a result the crocodile constantly
haunts captain hook and follows him
around neverland hoping for another
nibble
luckily the crocodile also swallowed a
clock so he can be easily detected by
the distinctive sound of ticking
emanating from his tummy
hook's encounters with the crocodile
make for some of the funniest moments in
the film
but it also stirs up some questions
within the discerning adult mind
specifically one can't help but wonder
why hook doesn't just organize a group
of his men to execute the beast so he no
longer has to live in perpetual fear
he's a badass pirate captain in charge
of a ship loaded with dangerous men
cannons and other weapons he should put
those to good use against the crocodile
so he can move on with his life
plus the croc doesn't seem to be too
elusive or quick moving
however like most kids adults should
overlook this leap in logic and enjoy
the timeless comedy of these two
fighting it out
an uncomfortable aspect of peter pan
comes into focus when analyzing the
questionable relationship between peter
and wendy
the two technically meet for the first
time after he breaks into the nursery
window at night while her parents are
out
which is unnerving enough however peter
had to have been there at least once
before while she was sleeping
considering wendy found his misplaced
shadow in the nursery
which definitely amps up the creep
factor then things get even more
uncomfortable
while considering the weighty decision
of whether she should go with a stranger
to a strange land
wendy wonders aloud what her mother will
think peter being unwise in the ways of
the world
asks wendy what a mother is to which she
replies
a mother's someone who who loves and
cares for you
and tells you stories good you can be
our mother
moments after this statement wendy
declares she's so excited to see peter
that she's going to give him a kiss
and not in the motherly sort of way this
has some weird freudian connotations to
say the least and it sets a bit of an
odd
undertone between the two throughout the
rest of the film
in the latter half of the movie wendy
sings a touching song called your mother
and mine
it's a sweet melody praising motherly
love soothing enough to lull her rowdy
brothers and the lost boys into a
relaxed blissful state
wendy's song even brings the pirates to
tears one pirate in particular mr smee
captain hook's comical boson is shown
crying while pulling up his shirt to
reveal a classic mom tattoo on his chest
making this one of the film's more
memorable and humorous moments
even tough guys love their mamas and
when watching this scene as an adult it
genuinely pulls on the heartstrings and
makes shmi's actions far more relatable
as a kid it's easy to take songs about
mothers for granted but once you've
moved out on your own your mom
isn't as easily accessible and distance
makes the heart grow fonder
more than a few adults watching this
movie probably found themselves getting
misty during this touching tribute to
mothers everywhere
they say you should never meet your
heroes and for those who idolize
mermaids this is particularly true while
watching peter pan
mermaids are generally depicted as
friendly benevolent creatures
especially in such films as splash or
the little mermaid however neverland's
resident
merfolk have darker natures which wendy
learns to her detriment while exploring
the island with peter
as it turns out peter is quite the
ladies man and
wendy finds herself vying for his
attention while he catches up with
fangirling mermaids in a neverland
lagoon
once they notice wendy however the
mermaids switch from flirtatious vixens
to jealous tyrants
while peter looks on laughing the
mermaids attempt to pull her under the
water
this is the second time wendy nearly
meets her fate at the hands of one of
peter's female friends
and like tinkerbell the mermaids own up
to their true intentions
in sociopathic like fashion the mermaids
acknowledge
exactly what they were trying to do we
were only trying to drown her
after losing his temper early in the
film george darling takes his
frustrations out on nana the canine
nanny by
banishing the poor dog outside to her
lonely drafty dog house
it's sadly ironic as she's the least
chaotic and most helpful member of the
entire family
this is extra cruel considering she's
not just any dog
nana thinks of herself as a nursemaid
and that she belongs
inside watching over the children she
does all the things a traditional
caretaker would
modifying some activities to accommodate
her lack of opposable thumbs
it's hard not to marvel at her
incredible dexterity and ability to
carry out a multitude of domestic tasks
even professionally trained dogs could
learn a thing or two from nana's
extensive skill set
and yet the darling family seems to take
her entirely for granted
for example while george's angrily
pacing about
making a scene over his outfit nana
continually tries to clean up and care
for the kids in the background
nana is so loyal that when george
struggles to find the rope to tie her up
outside
she pauses mid-banishment to find it for
him while she's just another humorous
character for kids to enjoy many adults
watching the film probably wish they
could have their own nana around the
house
although some of peter pan's content
hasn't aged too well
one of its spin-off movies more than
stands the test of time
directed by steven spielberg 1991's hook
imagines a life where peter falls in
love with wendy's granddaughter moira
and leaves neverland to start a family
of his own it's a heartwarming fantasy
featuring a stellar cast
including robin williams as peter pan
dustin hoffman as captain hook and julia
roberts as tinkerbell
ironically the once carefree boy grows
into an incredibly stiff-necked
workaholic with a fear of heights
he's also too busy climbing the
corporate ladder to spend any quality
time with his kids
but daily life is interrupted for
peter's family when captain hook kidnaps
his children and takes them back to
neverland
peter is forced to face his past in
order to save his family's future
in the process he remembers what's truly
important in life
reconnects with his inner child and
finds redemption with his loved ones
it's a grand adventure exploring a
boldly reimagined neverland but
it's also loaded with fun callbacks to
the 1953 classic
granted critics weren't especially fond
of it when it first hit theaters but
nevertheless hook is a joyous
family-friendly ride
plus the special effects still hold up
the musical score is excellent
and best of all the movie doesn't
contain any of the outdated and cringy
moments that only adults would notice
from the original animated version
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite classic movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]